china is empowered economically in part
because we're addicted to very cheap
goods
um and and we didn't hold china either
to its
you know certain promises that it was
supposed to keep um when it joined the
world trade organization we've kind of
let china
have its way with the world
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest is returning for her
second time on the show she
is the new york editor of spectator usa
melissa chen welcome back to the show
hi constantine hi francis thanks for
having me back oh it's so good to have
you back listen
uh we talked to you last time i think it
was about september 2019.
we talked primarily about china the way
it's using its power in the world
the impact that the ccp is having
on all of us wherever we live well uh
one or two things have happened since
then
that have made that even more a thing
that is present in our lives talk to us
about
what you've seen over the last year and
a half i mean
needless to say at the time that we were
taping it it was not on anyone's
radar really unless you were a china
watcher or you know really focused on
geopolitics
but you know somewhere around october
2019
things were already brewing in wuhan on
the ground
and our lives were about to be
completely upended in ways that you know
we just couldn't anticipate
um and when 2020 hit everything
hit the fan and you know it's been a
really interesting
year coronavirus has kind of accelerated
so much of of the trends so you know
almost
every trend that we've seen um whether
it's uh
in in work you know working from home
whether it's
on globalization uh supply chain
sovereignty or even just the concern
about china and china's role in the
world all these trends have really been
kind of
accelerated or at least brought to the
forefront in in the last in the last
year or so
um and and china's action since then has
has really not been that of a
responsible world actor um and so stuff
that i was talking about in in 2019 to
both of you
um has really become relevant in a way
that in 2020 made me seem like
you know i was some sort of like a a a
psychic or something but but the trends
were already there
and and the signs were already there and
and you know sev
i would say like several people you know
in even in the trump administration
had already acted in ways to to counter
china's increasing assertiveness um
but but look at you know bipartisan
agreement on china right now look at
popular opinion in
in america i think uh 90 of people
in america actually agree that china is
is a competitor and a rival it is not
you know a partner to the united states
we're not going to be able to
develop and get rich together we are
actually geo strategic rivals
um and so all these have really kind of
shifted in the last year
um and it's a very profound like
paradigm shift
and you say it's a very profound
paradigm shift and we've seen
you know what's happened with the
coronavirus i mean how much
responsibility should china take for
this
well i mean it's really interesting
because you know we're talking at a time
now when
the whole lab leak hypothesis has been
you know sort of
shored up again and so it's it's
percolating in the press
um something that was completely
apparently a debunked conspiracy for the
last year
um you know since early early on i would
say in january february there were
people talking about this
what are the odds that you know in the
city where there were two
not not just one there were actually two
labs um that
house bl4 facilities uh studying these
bat coronaviruses would be
the the the source or or the the first
place where
covet 19 shows up um the virus stars
cov2
and you know oakum's razor which is
really
you know a very basic principle of
parsimony that
that the scientific method uh is is
modeled on
um really should have been at play right
because
what is the most obvious uh guess here
and instead of kind of investigating
this
possible theory as a hypothesis
alongside
others which was you know the reigning
theory of the day was really about the
zoonotic transmission at the juan and
seafood market from
bats to some sort of mystery animal
which was surmised to be
a pangolin um in the end
you know we reflexively the scientific
community governments and our entire
media class dismiss the lab league
hypothesis as some sort of
um you know racist or just debunked
conspiracy
we shouldn't even go there um and and
really it's it's it's a failure on
you know what eric weinstein would call
our
sort of communal sense making apparatus
um
the institutions that run on media
really decided
on gating this narrative and and
preventing people from asking questions
if you
happen to you know zero hedge early on
was banned from twitter
um and all over facebook was banning you
know anyone that was
posting or removing posts that even
suggest that it might have been a lab
leak
and and you know even without the lab
leak
even if if this you know china was found
to be to be lying i i
i think that um if you look back at the
initial cover-up enough damage had been
done
um how we you know the country
persecuted
the whistleblowers and how it tried to
kind of hamstring the investigations
i mean on what planet does you know
the the country that the pandemic
started in gets to
pick who gets to sit
on the so-called independent inquiry
that the who sent
one year after the entire incident
happened more than one year actually
and and also after scrubbing the alleged
crime of the scene which was supposedly
the the seafood market which
we know from interviews you know where
um the the vendors did not actually sell
any of the meats in question whether it
was pangolin
or bat so there were there are just so
many questions and china's behavior
ever since um ever since the the
pandemic broke out has just been
um just very very suspect and and
retaliating against any country like
australia
that um was suggesting merely for an
independent inquiry
and melissa i'm going to jump in there
because as you were listing off all the
different meat i i was worried about
francis getting hungry
but uh listen i i there's another aspect
to all of this
which i find really interesting which is
neither you or us who are particularly
huge fans of donald trump
but how much of the failure to react
adequately failure to investigate
properly
failure to take the appropriate action
in the circumstances
was simply about the fact that people
hated donald trump
so much that when he said we actually
need to shut the border
to chinese people coming from china
because that's where the virus is
originated from when he said
we need to investigate whether this was
man-made in the lab etc
when all of these attempts were being
made kind of the mainstream
saw it through the lens of donald trump
and therefore
failed to take action as a result
whereas now many of the things that he
was saying at the time
particularly about the origin of the
virus calling it the china virus
closing borders this is something
actually the left is now demanding
yeah it's 80 to 90 um the reason
why i think you know we've um kind of
dropped the ball on this or
the press has because if you if you look
at how
how a lot of the press frames these
stories anything
that you know we're now judging whether
a policy or or whether
something is true based on who is saying
it
and and this this phenomenon has really
been exposed during the last four years
during the trump administration
where where if something is going to
help or or hurt
the uh trump administration it you know
that's when the press decides to
upregulate or down regulate the story
um and and they decide the framing so
when when trump
you know went hard on china um the press
saw this as an opportunity
to present it as trump abdicating his
culpability which
to be fair to him um you know i think
initially
he had the right instincts to shut the
border but
but he wavered on sort of um later on
kind of
you know either downplaying the the
virus or or
saying ridiculous things during the the
press conference it didn't really help
um he wasn't a a excellent kind of like
public health crisis kind of leader um
and and you know he's not good at
science communication either he's
probably i mean
there were many comical moments during
you know the press conferences
but on the other hand his instincts on
many of these
uh initial steps were right um it played
to
his kind of his biases to to you know be
sh to be a bit more restrictive on on
immigration and
shutting down borders and so you know he
got excoriated in the press
and you saw this remarkable thing which
i still think you know i refused to let
the press memory hold this
but people flipped right so initially
the republicans were
we're reacting very strongly this is
serious we need to shut the borders
uh you had navarro and trump kind of
insisting on this
um uh and they were banning flights from
europe and i remember
you know these images at the airport
they were all shown on tv and it was
chaos
and of course the press was saying this
was just racist i think joe biden also
said it was actually xenophobic
um and and then you had this remarkable
switch later on
when you know the trump administration
realized also that
shutting down lockdowns would actually
hurt the economy and the one thing that
gets incumbents re-elected is always
a good economy and and so they started
flipping their position
and and now you know the the lockdown
party became the democrats and they
wanted to
uh to basically shut the borders and and
i mean
look at today joe biden's instinct was
to shut down
uh the moment there was this nasty
variant that was going on in india was
to actually shut down travel from india
um you know an act that was so-called
racist just one year ago
and and so you see this ridiculous
flipping almost as if
no one is holding any position based on
principle
and it's it's just a sign of how
this political divisiveness and
partisanship is making
governance during a public health crisis
so completely
sclerotic it's a really good point mel
but it's not also the problem as well
you know that we've bought into this
idea of the globalized world being a
universal positive
you can get your goods from china you
can get this from india
but what coronavius has actually shown
is that the more interlinked we are
i mean the more vulnerable we are as a
society yeah i mean
you know that the nature of the virus
doesn't
respect any borders and it's very
progressive like that
um well and and the two things that
really popped up was
ppe the issue of you know where rpps
were coming from
and initially china was shoring up the
supply knowing that this was happening
knowing that
uh the west would actually have a harder
time trying to react given that most of
the
raw materials and the you know the
manufacturing capacity was actually in
china
and so there was this moment when you
know we had a hard time trying to
acquire these things not to mention the
confusion over
communication on masks and their
effectiveness at the beginning which
obviously
has caused a lot of problems um and
later on you know when it came to
vaccine raw materials that's
that's that's become another issue where
you know
even the eu is is is re-looking at this
issue because we've outsourced
vaccine manufacturing to parts of asia
and when you know this should all be
seen as something that is
part of you know national security um
vaccines ppe in a world where pandemics
can just kind of
um you know just spread like like
wildfire
um and well if you look at also you know
what happened
uh in the last i would say in the last
year is that
the the sort of e-commerce platforms
kind of
grew bigger right so your mom-and-pop
stores really suffered
but your amazons of the world they are
the ones that not only survived
but they got their power kind of their
market power got got far more entrenched
and and it did get far more entrenched
do you think we're going to see a
reversion back to people wanting to shop
local buying
american products buying british
products or do you think that when this
crisis is over we're just going to go
revert back to the status quo
um i think there there are really two
forces you know it's interesting because
joe biden has not actually
rolled back any of trump's policies
vis-a-vis
china um in fact he's been kind of
sticking to
an america first policy that the press
often
excoriated trump for for for supporting
um and you know i mean in fact biden's
uh
uh deputy spokesperson at the state
department said
that um you know when when we were
thinking of of how to address
the the crisis in india the pandemic has
been raging there a second wave
um and he said you know the world has an
interest in seeing americans get
vaccinated before
before everybody else and that was a
response that
you know that if this had come from
pompeo's state department
that that would have been like a
complete public outcry and meltdown
over this terrible america first policy
but
quietly america first has been rolled
forward we are taking care of
um you know our supply chains our um our
needs
first and and it's just interesting that
you know when this administration is
doing it it's it's not receiving the
same kind of pushback as the previous
one
um and and i think so many people have
become aware of
chinese influence in you know in this
open
liberal society that we all live in um
that includes you know
basically all throughout the west the
members of the eu have also kind of
woken up to this and
you know they're thinking of cutting
back on their trade deals
um and well i i just it's
to be honest like the the american
public has has kind of like
woken up to china as a geopolitical
threat and i think
um you know given the bipartisan
consensus too that
that likely moving forward people are
going to be a lot more careful
about you know pushing back china
chinese narratives in hollywood
uh chinese influence in our university
shutting down
confucius institutes and and even
products
so you know um i think there is
potentially a bill that's going to be
advanced about um
whether or not a product is like to
label products where they come from
you start to see sanctions now on any
products that
might have slave labor um might have
been you know parts of it might have
been assembled in xinjiang
which the united states under pompeo and
secretary blinken
has declared as you know china has been
committing genocide against the uyghurs
so you're starting to see more
legislative action
and and just more political will by
people to say
no enough we've all woken up to to the
reality that
it was such a terrible idea for us to
engage
with china for the last 40 years um not
only did they not liberalize
but you know we've become more like them
we've you know
their authoritarian model has has been
exported
well i was actually going to ask you
about that very point melissa because
uh i know you watched our interview with
neil ferguson the historian i should say
not not the epidemiologist
uh and what this is one of the questions
that i put to him which is
lockdowns he says have never been done
before in this way and probably because
we didn't have the technology to be able
to
to stay at home but also for other
reasons and really we've imported that
from china
unfortunately copying china is
a way of importing into free societies
the kind of software of of the unfree
society
i dread uh to see any more articles
of the form we should learn from china
it's going to be the chinese century
look how smart they are because that
just an invitation to
to import totalitarian ways of doing
things
yes in the past in time of emergency
we have restricted civil liberties we
did it in both world wars in quite
drastically actually
but everybody understood uh in the world
wars that it was a temporary state of
emergency
that would be ended as soon as the war
was over
the problem with doing it in a pandemic
is that it's
quite easy to argue that in fact it's
never going to be over
because the virus will always be out
there and then
this is one of the typically
totalitarian sounding slogans you hear
there's no no safety it's not over until
it's until there are no cases at all
anywhere in the world
now if you make that argument you will
be able to justify covert restrictions
forever and i do think this has been an
opportunity
for a power grab by state bureaucracies
and i know that you're someone who cares
about civil liberties a lot how
you know how do you feel about the fact
that sort of like we look to an
authoritarian communist dictatorship
to decide what we do in our countries
now
i think neil's point was interesting
because he said what we did in the west
was kind of the worst of both worlds
he said that you know we we didn't shut
down
and then we had this like almost locked
down in perpetuity
with different weird codes um you know
i think the problem is that you can't
pick china's
outcomes without china's system
and at the end of the day you know we
don't have
an oppressive surveillance totalitarian
state
not yet not not yet
um but but we just we just don't and you
know if you compare the other kind of
liberal democracies that did
lock down very hard um i would say new
zealand and australia are very good
examples
um you know is is it worth it in the end
uh especially economically these
countries are
you need to trade they need their
tourists dollars for for their economy
and it's impacting their you know
economy in a way that
we haven't really ascertained i think
we're not good at talking about
trade-offs and and in the sense that we
are still
living in this moment and living in the
crisis evaluating whether or not all
these policies have been
worth trade-offs um i i hate this
narrative that you know every time you
you try to criticize something like you
know overhandedness by the authorities
you will get
oh you're just trying to kill grandma
you just don't like you know oh great
like two people are dead or
it's it's it's just such a terrible way
to talk about
you know on a macro level in society
whether
a policy was worth it has it is it worth
our kids
being out of school for the last one
year more than a year now in some cities
here in the united states
um it you know surely this is something
that
we've already known now a year of of
science and data have been collected
and and we know that this virus actually
discriminates and it is by
age um and so i think we're starting to
at least be in a position to look back
and say well maybe maybe we shouldn't
have done that
um but these are conversations that
cannot happen in a place like china
you know i mean they're not allowed to
have conversations like that and
hopefully this is something that we we
can be honest and look back and and
learn from it i'm just not very you know
optimistic
that that we will yeah and i i
share your pessimism because i'm
naturally pessimistic anyway i'm
miserable
francis do you like biscuits stupid
question
if you like biscuits as much as him you
have to try
zingy berry bakery they're a small
family-run bakery that make
award-winning sweet cookies and savory
crackers
francis will explain how many awards
they want weren't you francis
the sumptuous cookies are made with
whole grain oats and real butter while
their savory crackers are made with
whole grain oats
and are both wheat and dairy free
they've got a brilliant offer all you
have to do is enter
our code which is of course triggered on
your first order and you'll not only get
10
off they'll give you free delivery as
well that's 10
off and free delivery on your first
order with our code which is triggered
go to zingerberrybakery.co.uk the link
is in the description
it's zingerberrybakery.co.uk and get
your biscuits today i think i'm eating
too many biscuits
never heard him say that before wow
did it surprise you how malleable people
were
and how readily they were to give up
civil liberties like in this country
the right to protest just evaporated and
we all went yeah what's the problem
oh it depends on the kind of protest
right
so i think that was the the hypocrisy
was
kind of aired out very openly when um
you know certain policies were applied
very selectively and very very
hypocritically um you know things that
were not okay
under one circumstance we're suddenly
okay and one of the
effects of this is that i think the
trust in our institutions have
really crumbled like the last year has
has seen trust in media crumble trust in
international organizations like the
w.h.o crumble
the u.n um and and partly it's because
of this selective application
uh you know one side's narratives favor
the other side no you can't protest um
civil liberties for for me but not for
the that kind of attitude
um and and it's just it's been very
destructive and
you know as society continues to evolve
um and the trust breaks down i just
don't really know how we're gonna
recover from that so i'm a lot less i
know you end up that interview with
with neil and on a very positive note
because we've been in
darker places before um but i'm just i
don't
i can't see a way out for us i mean
it's very very succinctly put which then
begs the question
how do we roll back can we roll back or
is this
just a moment in time where it's been an
unassailable rupture and there's no
going back from it
um you know i people
seem to have um a resiliency
but i don't know how permanent these
changes are you know
you're starting to hear people going
back to work they want to go back to
work they want to go back to the pub
we need our apolitical spaces back like
we need sports back
but sports in a way that you know was
like before
um without all the politics kind of
embedded and all the nonsense
um and and i think it really depends on
a lot of that
um you know whether we have these spaces
to
come together and and and sort of
interact in in ways that the the more
uh a political spaces and common hobbies
that we can engage in
the the better the chance we have to
to kind of get back to the way things
were um but i'm kind of afraid that
that ship has really sailed um you know
the wall has kind of been pulled from
from the eyes of most people the media
has been
the media's hypocrisy has been laid bare
um you know the idea that like
silences violence and and sort of
gaslighting about
racial narratives and things like that
have really been sort of
inflamed um in the last year so i don't
know if we're we're going to be able to
come back from something like that
and you mentioned president biden uh you
mentioned that he's continuing many of
the policies that donald trump had on
china
are you optimistic that he's now that
as i said the media is free to agree
with him when he takes action on china
let's say and other things
now that he has a bit more room for
maneuver he is certainly less
uh provocative with his language and the
way he talks than donald trump which was
wasn't was never going to be a challenge
to achieve uh
with all of that put together do you
think he
will be able to manage this problem
effectively
you know he's less provocative but he
has some
blind spots which i think helps china
especially in the arena of
propaganda and soft power
biden for example in his first executive
order
signed um you know an anti-asian hate
crime bill
and a lot of this had been kind of
posturing and several republicans in the
senate
voted against the bill not because they
were anti
you know they they they supported hate
crimes against asians
um they voted against it because they
were concerned about very broad
language um that might implicate you
know
people when they're talking about covet
19 and things like
talking about the origins of covet 19
could be considered
racially discriminated uh discriminating
language
and therefore you know be considered a
hate incident
and so you know these kind of broad um
uh overreaching language in
and in tackling anti-asian kind of
racism
has i think been a boon to to to china
because they know they can soften
criticism
abroad um it's kind of like the same
forces you see when
when uh people try to attenuate
criticisms
of islam by saying that any criticism of
islam is islamophobia
um and it's it's playing this like
bigotry
race card to to a very effective way to
just silence criticism
and and china's deploying it masterfully
uh
my issue with biden is really on this
front where i think he is
more amenable due to his political
position
you know he is a democrat and i think
he's more liable to that kind of
uh influence the point you're talking
about china deflecting criticism
it's the communist playbook the soviet
union did this exact thing
uh when america would criticize the
soviet union
uh my ancestors would reply saying well
what about african americans in america
having a rough time
and that was the deflection that
justified gulags and all the rest of it
right it's it's a it's a very classic
tactic
and uh if you look at you know the wolf
diplomats
um we're very active on twitter these
are chinese
uh you know either um ambassadors uh or
or state media heads they are very
aggressive in their rhetoric
and very happy to point out and weigh in
on u.s domestic issues they weigh in
on the capital riots uh on january 6
they weighed in on
george floyd they're using these
domestic issues
um in a way to to basically manipulate
public opinion and it's actually very
very effective
it is very effective and we saw an
example of soft power
quite literally this week with john cena
he was in what fast a furious 938 or
something like that
and uh he he had to do a public apology
right and he did it in mandarin and it
was posted
on on chinese twitter it was so painful
to watch
um you know it's i i i
kind of made a tweet a joke about it
because his signature phrase has been
this like hand wave where he's like you
can't see me i'm like
yeah like you can't see his balls like
he just lost the balls
um you know just just count towing like
that in
in such a brazen way um but
you know could you blame him the you
know the chinese market has long
exceeded for
international box office sales um has
long exceeded the u.s market so
china now is an expert in just using its
economic leverage
just bullying countries to to to toe its
its communist party line whether the
issue is tibet whether the issue is
taiwan or hong kong
um if it doesn't like what you're saying
if it doesn't like that
you know the website whether it's nasa
whether it's delta airlines or marriott
listed taiwan or macau as a
country and not a territory as part of
china
it's able to use its economic muscle to
just change
that um and and if you want access to
the chinese market you you have to buck
up you have to comply
if not you're booted out and you know
tech companies our tech companies at
least have have made that stance they
are booted out they are actually blocked
from the chinese market
um but but you know brands consumer
brands like they
they're liable like they they have to
participate if they don't they
completely lose out globally
melissa i was going to ask you because
we're having this conversation and look
you know i agree with you about uh
chinese sort of
soft power or what you might discover
describe as soft aggression
influence etc but no no i don't think
none of us
no one watching this would want like
another cold war
or a confrontation with china but do you
think
essentially there is no way to deal with
china without confronting them because
there's no way to to get them to
to behave as you you put it more
responsibly
well i think decoupling was the way to
do it you know the
the cold war i mean there's an argument
to be had that the cold war actually
we didn't win the cold war it didn't end
and china is the torchbearer
but but the analogy of the cold war
breaks down because we actually engaged
with china
um economically and we didn't do that
with the ussr
you know we let the ussr basically bleed
out financially and it collapsed
because of its imperialist adventures
and
and eventually was just financially
unstable but that's not the case for
china
you know china isn't powered
economically in part because we're
addicted to very cheap goods
um and and we didn't hold china either
to its
you know certain promises that it was
supposed to keep um when it joined the
world trade organization we've kind of
let china
have its way with the world on its terms
and and not held it accountable for
things like
pillaging you know intellectual property
uh corporate espionage even these like
massive
cyber hacking um sort of scandals
you know stealing all the opm data and
things like that so
we just haven't really held china
accountable to some sort of like
international norms we've let them have
a pass because we
just wanted to trade with them and and
in a way we've
really committed a terrible mistake um
it's not going to go the way of the ussr
because we're now entangled economically
but there's still ways to i think
decouple um there
they're especially industries that we
need to decouple for sure
so if you look at anything that um that
involves say like
making parts for the electric grid
um these are things that are implicated
in our national security to let china
build our 5g networks you know that is
why would you
do that right so so there are ways to to
at least
identify the industries that are crucial
that are potentially you know kind of
weak spots if we let china
even contribute certain certain parts
and and decouple
from that and now we were talking about
soft power grabs can you see in the next
few years china making a hard power grab
maybe invading taiwan they've certainly
had their eyes on it for a long time now
the uh us navy estimates that the
chances are that china would actually
try to do that in the next seven years
um and that's good news
yeah you know and it's one of those
things like i think the us
appetite for intervention military
intervention after afghanistan
and after iraq is pretty much zero so
i i don't know how you know u.s public
opinion
uh would shape the the um sort of
capacity for
our government to to do anything or the
west to do anything in general
um but but an invasion of taiwan is
egregious
and if you don't stop china there
where would you stop i mean taiwan is
democratic
it's it's independent it's been you know
its own country for
since 1949. yes it was a military
dictatorship for a while but it
liberalized
um the nationalists liberalized in in
ways that makes taiwan completely the
most actually the most
uh vibrant liberal democracy in all of
asia was the first asian country to
actually
um introduce and allow marriage equality
gay marriage
so taiwan is a beacon of freedom and a
very important counterpoint to this
narrative that
you know asians kind of uh need a
different system because they're
culturally distinct
uh that's something that china has been
repeating for a long time
the ccp that you know asian populations
prefer collectivism but the taiwanese
and
and the chinese have the same dna and
they're they're separated by you know a
body of water
but they have two different systems
those two countries are thriving in
different ways
and it's such an important counterpoint
to china that it and
and you know beyond the fact that china
sees it as
rightfully there so the historical
baggage all the more makes china wants
to reunify
and take taiwan by force xi jinping has
said this
there's just like this is one of those
issues that has like zero wiggle room
for the current regime and and if they
take china if they
if china does take taiwan what's next
japan is right there
you know it's it's a power in in the the
pacific area
you have hawaii it's really close to you
know the the west coast of
uh the united states so it's a direct
military threat
and um i mean personally i'm in favor of
intervening we have to intervene to do
something if china ever takes
uh ever takes taiwan i mean you say that
we have to intervene but we haven't so
far we looked at the situation with hong
kong i mean
a couple of leaders came out you know
boris johnson said something i can't
really remember it but it was largely
pointless can't you just see the west
shrugging their shoulders
again well i think the problem with hong
kong was the treaty that was signed at
the end of the day
you know by 2047 hong kong was going to
return to china no matter what
china just sped up the process and and
dishonored the agreement
did not grant 50 years of autonomy one
country two systems
to to hong kong um and so
it was really just a matter of like time
it just
you know it did everything was gonna do
in 2047
20 years ahead of schedule um in
taiwan's case there would be a very
egregious military
intervention that china you know that
there's no agreement
with taiwan actually this is one of
those ongoing conflicts that that
just like palestine and israel that that
have been you know
since kind of the the initial world
order really post world war ii
it just hasn't been solved and um
i i i just don't see i just don't see
those those two things as
as similar but speaking of things being
similar not similar in israel and
palestine
uh have you been surprised uh at the
difference between the way
uh you know people who argue that uh
muslim palestinians are being oppressed
by israel
don't seem to be quite as upset about uh
being
uh butchered and and imprisoned by by
the ccp
has that surprised you melissa you know
it's funny i actually thought of that
it's not something i ever tweeted or um
or posted about but
that i got into an argument with uh none
other than mia khalifa
the uh lebanese former porn star
an activist and and i i remember
thinking to myself like
because she's identifies as muslim and
you know
why why is this such a a big cause but
but these you know palestinian activists
are just so silent on this one issue
and it's just so interesting how these
issues map onto political tribes because
if you were consistent if if say caring
about muslim oppression is something
across the board
that you know is a principle you hold
surely you would speak up about
something like that
and it's interesting because you know if
you look at the
the signing of the the u.n the letter to
the united nations
um i think it was majority of the muslim
majority countries
in the gulf in the middle east um
did not sign the latter and that
includes pakistan
um to excoriate china for for
its uh oppression of the uyghurs and
xinjiang
and the reason obviously is because
china is doing a lot of business
and deals and is involved with these
countries
um in the belt and road initiative where
it's
you know building infrastructure giving
loans in the case of
countries like saudi arabia it's even
exporting its
its technology you know the panopticon
that it built the
techno surveillance state technology
that china is using
and so because of all these deals i mean
if you if you look at how
um many of these countries look to china
as a model you have you have two
options in the world either you are
going to liberalize and become a liberal
democracy
um or you're going to go down the china
route and and
become an authority an autocratic you
know regime
and for many of these countries in the
middle east they've
it's pretty clear which model they want
to pursue um philosophically they're far
more aligned with the chinese model
and china is paving the way so
you know they're going to just quieten
their their criticisms
and that is a good point but it's also
as well china's model let's be honest
it's far more effective in many ways
there's not this constant turnover of
leadership you can get a hell of a lot
done with slave labor
exactly no this is some i mean i grew up
in singapore and and on the scale
from you know china to to
the us and for somewhere in the middle
it's really kind of like this this
interesting hybrid
and um um i've heard these arguments
since i was a kid you know about um
the democracy is messy democracy is
um you know it leads to very slow
sclerotic inefficient kinds of
government um
and and something like the pandemic
really threw this into very sharp focus
right we saw how effective
some of these authoritarian countries
were in um in clamping down
in nailing people into their apartments
and forcing social distancing
tracking we can't even get vaccine
passports because
you know half our people will revolt and
and i mean i when bill de blasio you
know put out a number
saying like there's this hotline um all
new yorkers if you
see people not wearing the mask outside
not social distancing
call this number and report and snitch
on your fellow new yorkers
and people just saw that and they
started sending him dick pics
[Music]
i was so proud of i was like oh we're
kind of screwed but
also very proud of america i mean on one
hand that's
you know that's bad in terms of the
outcomes for the virus but i'd rather
live in a place
where people don't want to snitch on
each other on each other
rather than a place where there's just
so much distrust
and and that people are snitching on
each other all the time
but but the reality is that you know one
of these places is going to do a lot
better it's going to have zero deaths
and it's again this kind of contrast
goes all the way back to benjamin
franklin the trade-off between security
and liberty
it's a very good point and well-made
melissa i think we'll leave china
there for now hey kkk do you like
feeling
silky and smooth like a sexual dolphin
never talk to me again what if i told
you that manscape to brought out a new
and improved lawnmower
3.0 that allows you to be fresh
and trim for the ladies down below
i'm married the last time i was fresh
and trimmed down below jimmy savile was
a respected children's entertainer i'm
going to ignore that
the lawnmower has a cutting-edge ceramic
blade which reduces the risk of having
an accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot
you know los huevos oh right
plus it's waterproof which means you can
groom in the
shower and it has an led light so you
can really get an
accurate and precise trim excellent
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes
so you can do your whole area in about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger 2-0 that is trigger two zero
that's
twenty percent off with free shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code
which is of course tricker two zero
your boss will thank you excellent
we've got a little bit of time left and
you talk about new york and the united
states and some of the things that
have been happening there including the
uh certainly a wave of reporting about
anti-asian hate crime i don't know uh
how accurate
tell us is it has there been a massive
increase or is it just something that
people have been focusing on more than
before
so you know there's been an increase in
violent crime
all across the board in america um in
some cities it's really stark i think in
portland it's been a
sixteen hundred percent increase in
violence
well they're reimagining public safety
aren't they so that's good oh they are
yeah the police right which is related
um and
you know the the the data on on
anti-asian crime
or you know the sort of like what we're
observing the the discourse
is based on three sources one of them is
just these social media videos that keep
popping up
which are terrible and heartbreaking you
know we're seeing these like elderly
asians kind of being
mugged being assaulted on the streets
usually in urban centers like
san francisco or los angeles um and
and they kind of go viral right um the
other the other two sources
one of which is a an interesting group
called stop aapi hate
which really showed up at the beginning
of 2020
um and and their statistics were thrown
around in a way that made it seem really
stark
um there's been a 3600 percent increase
in asian hate crimes uh which sounds
terrible and
you know if that were true would would
just really warrant some sort of uh
severe intervention but if you look at
um
how they collected their data it's very
suspect
uh they are based on a completely
self-reporting online portal
um and and many of the incidents that
are collected are not don't even
meet threshold of what you call a crime
some of them are
verbal shunning some of them are you
know simply
i didn't like the way this person looked
at me at the supermarket
so it's all based on on on self
reporting and then the third one which
which came out i think it was one of the
university of california was uh
compiled uh sort of early
2020 crime data looked at
you know hate crime reporting by by the
fbi
um in 16 cities across the united states
and found that there's been 150 percent
increase
that for me is the more relevant data
out of all of these and because that is
actually based on fbi statistics
and it's it's preliminary data we don't
really get all of 2020's data until
november of 2021 so we're still kind of
early
but this is preliminary and and they've
compiled it again this is
from 16 progressive most of them
progressive
run cities in the states and it does
look like there's an upswing
um but numbers of asian crimes actually
very low
in absolute numbers so if you look at
new york city for example in 2019 there
were three
anti-asian hate incidents three um in
2020 there were
28. so the the percent increase
from 3 to 28 is actually really high but
to put that number into
sharp relief um for
for anti-semitic hate crimes uh that
there is more than 150
just in new york so the narrative
about anti-asian hate crimes i think is
it seems like something is happening
we're seeing these videos
um is this meaningful in a way that
is this due to racial prejudice explicit
racial animus
or is this part of you know kind of
asians being part of this
um urban environment elderly especially
being a very vulnerable population
they know they probably keep their cash
underneath the mattresses they're not
using banking system
they live in china towns they're weak
they won't fight back they don't own
guns
um how much of this is opportunistic
crime that's part of the
ambient crime levels that are heightened
anyway
um all across the board how much of it
is actually
racially targeted and i think
his name is charles lehman had done he's
uh with the manhattan institute has done
some interesting time series so he took
that data that i
the last data set that i described the
fbi data and he looked at
um he plotted that over time and so what
you're seeing is an interesting spike
in march of 2020 just a little tiny
spike
which could be attributed to things like
the lockdowns and and
um you know just kind of the cove 19
related kind of crimes potentially that
was
in in 2020 but in 2021
when biden is president in
democratic-run cities
there has been another spike in march
2021
and so the idea that this is somehow due
to
white supremacy as the media has ran
with this narrative
is completely ridiculous because trump
is not even on social media
no one is out there spouting wuhan flu
or you know
wuflu or or china virus and the idea
that this is related to some sort of
rhetoric is
just completely bollocks but you can
make some interesting inferences why is
there a spike again
in and it's pretty significant in in
march of 2021
now if you correlate this with google
searches with media reporting could it
be copycat crimes could it be that just
awareness of the crime itself
makes people report the hate incidents
or the hate crimes
um in a way that you know they just
wouldn't have before so
there are a lot of reasons why
potentially you know there is this
weird spike in march um of 2021 but but
we don't really
know but it's certainly we can say that
it has nothing to do
with the the leading media narrative
which is apparently white supremacy well
for a star
quite a lot of the people that
committing these crimes don't seem to be
why um
so or exactly
uh but do you think there's an element
in terms of the way it's talked about
and the way that it's covered where
it's like you know once you introduce
identity politics then it becomes in the
interest of every single group
to become the victim and so when jews
get and you know i'm allowed to say this
because i'm from a jewish background
you'll be allowed to say this christ
view from
an asian background like everyone would
benefit from being in the victim group
because that's what society currently
values and ranks higher than the
non-victim groups do you think
a large part of it is like well people
are attacking us let's you know let's
make hay
yeah it's interesting because you're
right i i do agree with the
sort of like the victimhood kind of
correlating victim
status correlating with moral status
somehow in
in this society that we live in that you
know has
married intersectionality with critical
race theory
um but but asians in a way are are
kind of like i call it strajin girls
white people because
you know you're white sometimes when it
comes to
um when it comes to college admissions
and so or even like um
if you if you for college admissions
you're worse than why
yeah that's true yeah it's not possible
yeah it is possible just for just in
that one context
well and even like uh wages so if you
look at
uh you know income levels asians as a
group are actually have outburned whites
as a demographic
in in recent years so um you know under
those circumstances asians are
considered
white and therefore have to be adjusted
their populations
you know they're over represented
because and and they're white so
they're you know either you have to
abolish the the test
or or do something in a way to lessen
their their
uh demographic numbers in schools or at
the workplace
but on the other hand you know they're
suddenly people of color when it comes
to street violence when it comes to
um you know this uh invisibility on tv
or whatever other sort of cultural elite
causes that are being supported
right now and and so you see this like
weird bifurcation and the cynic in me
has always been well you know the
they know that the aapi group the
asian-american pacific islander group
which is another ridiculous bureaucratic
racial category that was invented
is a useful voting bloc and right now
it's a pawn in this political game
because as crt and sort of uh
this this narrative about about um
discrimination in college becomes more
obvious to asians
they're going to rebel against that and
and tend to vote
conservative and so the only way you're
going to bring them back into the
progressive fold
is is to drum up this narrative that
they are targeted that they are
victimized because of their race
um that is my guess about the dynamics
that are going on politically
um and so in a way you know asian
sort of uh elderly suffering you know
on the streets um has has become
a useful way to kind of milk this issue
politically when solving this issue
is really just a matter of solving crime
if you prosecute it if if we you know
provided mental health facilities for
many of these people who are attacking
these agents are actually
mentally ill but you know our
homelessness
problem has skyrocketed because of the
home because of the lockdowns
crime has skyrocketed and and we're not
solving the very thing that could
actually
help these people you know we're we're
blaming
it on on this entirely different um
reason which is you know if you get
the the the reasoning wrong
the root cause wrong you're gonna get
the policy wrong and the prescription
wrong and it's not going to do anything
so that's kind of where my frustration
is right now and
are people still thinking defunder
police is a good idea of we all accepted
that that was a crap idea brought on by
the insanity of a lockdown
actually it looks like a tide has been
turning and even among
african americans you know the the ones
who actually live in these
at-risk neighborhoods um the tide is
turning
people there is such strong data that
shows that
you know stronger policing actually
correlates with lower crime really
wow and and um
you know like andrew yang has been
kind of um criticized a lot by sort of
asian activists you know the kinds who
went to ivy leagues
um for for suggesting for merely
suggesting that one of the solutions to
prevent
to stop aapi hate is to increase
funding for the police and and put more
police resources in these neighborhoods
and you know it's just so funny how
these narratives shake out because he's
been targeted
he you know hit pieces were ran against
them for even suggesting that
because because somehow these asian
activists are very aligned with the blm
narrative
about you know how police actually
brutalize
uh communities of color and that we must
stand with them and if we don't stand
with black lives we don't stand with
asian lies which
again is trying to connect these causes
and and you know as the palestine
conflict kind of
erupted as well you start to see how
george floyd now intersects with
palestine when obviously has nothing to
do with each other
right so we we live in a time of like
globalization of narratives in a way
where every struggle has to be connected
to some original struggle and and
everything is collectivized and we're
not
evaluating things independently and
that's such a
good point and it's a fantastic place to
end the interview
uh melissa if people want to find you
online where is the best place to do
that
only fans
[Laughter]
that is how we will lead this interview
and it is going to get a million views
do you know what there's probably about
six losers on the internet who saw that
went great wasn't
um well the best way to find me is um on
twitter
which is my handle at miss ms mel mel
chan chen
or you can read my stuff in on the
spectator usa website um that's probably
the best way to find them
and before we let you go we have one uh
proper question for you and then we'll
do some locals only questions as well
so as you know our last question for the
main interview itself is
uh what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we still
should be talking about we're
one of the things that interests me that
i don't see much
discourse on is how
is it how did it come to be that
um you know a system like in the us
where where we have so-called a free
society that's kind of more in line with
the a brave new world kind of utopia
where you know
we we optimize for for pleasure and and
sort of
hedonism and
and and try to you know down regulate
pain and discomfort how this system the
brave new world system in the u.s and in
the west in general in europe
um compared to the totalitarian 1984
china system how these two
different systems actually end up
converging to look like the same thing
where we now because of safetyism and
the
you know of harm avoidance um and not
wanting to confront anything
that that makes us feel bad has led us
down
a weirdly totalitarian path
that you know our systems kind of end up
feeling
you know we have yelp for example review
systems that
that um you know are our steps removed
from china's social credit system
but not unlike it and you know so i find
that convergence interesting that
we have top-down top-down versus
bottom-up kind of freedom but or control
but they're meeting in the same place
and and it feels like we're still living
in dystopia
and it feels inevitable as well i think
to me uh but
it's a very good point and something
that i think is going to come into
sharper and sharper focus over the years
to come
uh which is when we will have you back
to talk about it some more melissa thank
you so much for
chatting with us thank you cheers and
thank you guys for watching at home we
will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or all show
all of them go out at 7 pm uk time take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic
episode and if you believe that the work
we do here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below